We've given you codes for the beginnings
of a weather provider class within
the data package that
extends content provider.
One of the tools that Android provides
to help write a content provider
is a UriMatcher,
which we are going to write shortly.
Filling out a UriMatcher is the third
step in building our content provider.
Content providers implement
functionality based upon
URIs passed to them.
Our content provider will
implement four types of URIs.
Each one of these URIs will be used to
execute different types of operations
against the underlying SQL databases.
For ease of implementation,
content providers typically tie each URI
type internally to an integer constant.
These integer constants have already
been added to the provided weather
provider class.
Android provides a UriMatcher
class to help match incoming URIs
to the content provider
integer constants.
This is important because we need to
have a way of knowing which type of URI
is passed into our content provider so
we can perform the requested operation.
Once we have the integer constants,
we can easily use them
in switch statements.
UriMatcher provides for an expression
syntax to match various URIs that
works a bit like regular expressions.
Hash symbols will match a number.
And an asterisk will match any string.
Here are some examples